in today's video i'm going to talk about
presentations
but not how to do and conduct them but
rather how to properly prepare for them
and the inspiration for today's video
was with a conversation that i recently
had
with another former mckinsey colleague
this person has a leadership position
and a big industry company
and this person was telling me you know
heinrich at my current company there are
always these presentations going on
they almost always start late and the
main reason for that is that people do
not prepare
properly for this presentation and this
is a problem and this is surely also an
area where i've seen many consultants
who significant mistakes which then were
perceived in a very negative way
both by clients but often also your
internal leadership your partners or
maybe part of the meeting as well
so welcome to another coffee break here
on my channel firm learning
my name is heinrich and on my channel i
want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career so
without further ado let's get into it
i prepared a slide with a couple of key
points that i want now present to you
let's get started so now i did prepare a
couple of points for you on this topic
of the right preparation
and the first point is really your
mindset
how are you thinking about that and here
i want to share
two things two essential points and the
first is that you should
make this your problem i've seen it so
many times that there were business
analysts junior consultants maybe
interns as part of the team
and then they left it to the project
lead to figure all these things out
this is clearly not how it should be now
this is not supposed to sound
too hierarchical but at least to me it
seems obvious that you as the junior
person
should make sure you to make these
things your responsibility
to keep this weight off the shoulders of
the more senior person in your team
very much related to this is then the
behavior in the meeting room in the
meeting
if you actually find out that something
is not working as planned not working as
expected
then here again i've observed that so
many times that there were associates
junior people
interns in the room but then they left
it up to the partner
or up to the project lead to fix certain
things
with the technical devices this will
surely not be perceived way
if you see that anything isn't working
properly you should jump
you should take that take responsibility
and make sure that it all works also for
the reason that in the room there will
often be some clients some other guests
then it would be great for the partner
to be able to entertain these people
have a cordial conversation with them
instead of them needing to fix all the
technical devices in the room
next is preparation of the room in here
trust we already had our experiences of
being in a meeting room
maybe it was quite a big room with many
many people present
but there was only one small microphone
in the middle of the room
and then people were not really able to
participate there was a person sitting
at the other end of the room
saying something but this person was not
being hurt in the room
because just the microphone
configuration did not allow that
and this of course is not great
especially if you are the host of such a
meeting you're inviting a significant
number of people
always make sure that the room set up
fits the audience that you're inviting
there
and if you're even somewhere else maybe
at the building of a client you're
booking a room and you are there and
realize it doesn't work then look out
maybe you find a second microphone and
second microphone device
maybe if you talk to the assistant of
the sponsoring board member
the assistant might be able to help you
you might be able to get some devices
out of one of the other meeting rooms
maybe that are close by
be there early look at the setup and
make sure that the setup actually suits
the needs of your audience
related to this point of preparation is
to make sure that you are
dialed in on time and again i've seen it
so many times you were there shortly
before the meeting not everyone is there
now it's exactly on time to start it
and then you realize oh we are not even
died in we are not even died into the
video conference yet we were not even
died into the telephone conference yet
or maybe it was not even clear whether
anybody was
dialing in from outside whether all
people are sitting there in the meeting
room
of course in these situations your
partner your project lead
will likely look at you as the junior
person as the associate
the expectation will be there that you
will have organized all this that you
will have this all top of your mind
what you need to do to get everybody in
everybody involved and then the last
point is organizing flip charts
whiteboards and similar pieces of
equipment so if you're working
for a consulting firm for you it's maybe
standard that in every room these things
are present but trust me that in many
client organizations this is
not the case so ask yourself what you
really need what will your meeting rely
on
and if you realize that you need these
things either bring them yourself if the
setup allows or make sure that we are
the personal assistant whomever you have
at your disposal to help you with these
things in the client organization
that you reach out to them and make sure
that it's all set up once you are there
and once you need it
next a couple of points on what you
should probably always carry with you as
a well-prepared associate
as a young professional who is setting
up and conducting meetings like this
first is adapters for beamers and
monitors so nowadays all people are
walking around with their macbooks you
will frequently find yourself in rooms
where there's maybe a beamer with an old
vga output an
hdmi cable any other of these standards
and often you elect the right
interfaces for your device make sure to
always
carry a bunch of adapters in order to be
able to connect all kinds of different
beamers and monitors
even if the technology is rather
outdated next little thing is a
presenter so something like
this this is also something i always
have in my bag it's a nice and easy
device you can plug it into every pc
and then you don't have to do this
little thing of you know somebody maybe
clicking
advancing the slides on the pc and then
someone else
presenting something and then this is
not really in sync maybe then someone is
already advancing to the next slide
where the presenter still wanted to talk
about the last slide
ah this is always very cumbersome it's
so great if you just always carry
presenter
plug it in the device give the presenter
to your partner to your project lead
whoever is
presenting and again this will make you
look as quite organized quite well
organized if you always carry these
things
have them with you and then at the right
moment in time you can just drag them
out plug them in and it just all
works next is to always carry with you
some additional spare audio conferencing
devices so as a consultant i was always
carrying with me a set of two
little audio spiders so these
combination devices where you have both
a microphone and a speaker
because with these you can easily plug
them into your pc
and then two of them you can often
combine them sync them
and then with two of them even in a
larger meeting room this usually always
gave you enough flexibility
to provide full audio and microphone
coverage
of a larger meeting room so here there
are different brands offering solutions
like that
i actually very frequently use the jabra
devices which i also own myself i will
link now in the video description some
links to these devices that i personally
use
so if you're interested in that just
check them out i also want to share some
points of advice on
online meetings online video meetings
because of course i very well understand
that many of these physical meetings are
not taking place at the moment
and here maybe some obvious things of
course make sure that you're sitting in
an area where you have stable internet
connection
and of course also not too much noise
surrounding you and this might sound
obvious but i still
very very vividly remember the
conversation of two partners and one of
my prior employers
where it was not discussed well the
senior consultant should be promoted
to project lead and one partner made a
very hard case against that
because this partner had an experience
with this consultant
but this consultant was conducting a
probably rather important client
conversation
from a train he was in an audio
conference from a train
due to the of course bad telephone
connection in trains he was dropping in
and off of the call all the time
and this partner was making the point
that apparently this consultant is not
taking his runs abilities seriously
enough
that this consultant should have made
sure that when he is on an important
client call
that he is not sitting in a train that
he is making sure that he has good
connection that he can conduct these
calls
in a professional manner as the client
will expect this consultant to so
frankly when i heard that i thought that
this was quite tough that only for one
incident like that
your promotion is questioned but
apparently obviously some people
things like that to some people this is
extremely important so make sure
you have these things in mind as well to
just not endanger your next promotion to
not endanger your career's way
another point on online video
conferences is of course the proper
technical setup
most people nowadays have laptops where
there is an integrated microphone and an
integrated camera
in most video conferences are just
conducted by sitting in front of a
laptop
using exactly these devices and i trust
this will be the case for most
regular interactions most regular
conferences but especially if you're
having some very important meetings with
very senior people
consider whether you don't want to
upgrade your equipment a bit
and you know in my current role i had
the pleasure to in the last month's
interview lots of people lots of
candidates and you would be surprised
how many of these people
were sitting in dark environments you
could barely properly see them due to
the low quality camera that they used in
the laptop
maybe there were also noise
interferences their audio was not very
clear
of course this will not help you to make
a great impression so think about that
don't you have one two three hundred
euro to spare
to invest in a proper microphone in some
basic lights
maybe even an external camera to
properly make sure that you have a nice
picture
with a couple of hundred bucks you will
be able to significantly improve your
video conferencing setup
and this might be very much worth the
investment especially for facing these
types of situations that are now
highlighted
now in one effort to combine all of
these points i think that there's one
common denominator that really will
define whether you are able to prepare
yourself in the right way or not
because the truth is even if you're 10
minutes early 10 minutes in the room
before the meeting starts
this will usually barely be enough to
connect all your devices to the other
devices
this will be barely enough preparation
time to make sure everything is set up
and works properly
but as soon as you have one little
problem as soon as one thing does not
work as expected
usually you will run out of time and you
will not be able to start the meeting on
time from my experience especially for
important meetings where you want to
make sure that
everything works smoothly you should be
in the meeting room at least 30 minutes
before the meeting start
to make sure and to give you enough time
to set everything up and to have this
fallback option that if
something is not working properly that
you at least have a chance
to find maybe a replacement device to
maybe get an additional microphone from
somewhere
to potentially call a technical support
person that often many client
organizations have
if you are not in the room 30 minutes
before the meetings start you will not
be able
to do this on time so as with most other
things in life as well
good preparation is key be sure that you
behave as a professional especially if
you're working in professional services
and a big part of that certainly is
to make sure that you prepare for your
important meetings in a very meticulous
and diligent way
and of course i do hope that this video
contained a couple of tips which will
help you to do exactly that
but now i would love to hear from you do
you have even more advice on this topic
to share that might be beneficial to
other members of the firm learning
community as well
i would very much appreciate to see
comments from you and of course as you
know every comment also helps with the
youtube algorithm so if you took any
value out of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
the channel
to stay up to date on all my content i'm
releasing new videos every single
saturday here on my channel
if you want to see even more from me i'm
also present on other channels such as
instagram ticktalk or twitch and i also
have a mailing list
you'll find the links to all these
medias below in the video description
and if you would like to learn more
about how to create presentations in the
style of leading consulting firms i once
created a fully fledged online course
exactly on the topic
again link to that in the video
description as well i also want to say
thank you to all the members of firm
learning
you're really making a great
contribution to the channel this is much
appreciated
and if you want to join as well just hit
the join button next to the subscribe
button so if you want to continue your
learning journey with this channel there
will be no videos appearing next to me
so feel free to check them out again i
release videos every single saturday so
see you again next week
until then good weekend to all of you
this is jaime from from learning
bye bye